happy UNESCO World Philosophy Day 2014
this is a day where we get to talk about
the discipline of philosophy in a more
broad popular public way and so I wanted
to mark the occasion by doing a video
specifically on public philosophy or
popular philosophy practical philosophy
some people think these are our you know
rigidly distinguished from each other I
think they kind of blend into each other
so this is in some respects a how-to
video giving you some ideas about if you
wanted to get into that sort of thing
how you might get involved in it it's
also a bit of a reflection and
reminiscence video on my own experience
in in doing this in case you don't know
me on Greg Sadler I have a YouTube
channel devoted specifically to
philosophy that's been around for about
four years I just rolled out a critical
thinking channel and this spring I'll be
rolling out some new channels as well
one on ethics one on the history of
philosophy probably went on continental
philosophy so again
happy world philosophy day now we're
going to talk about doing philosophy in
a public popular practical manner one
question that might occur to you to ask
is well why would you want to do
philosophy in a public way or in a
popular way you know why make it
practical aren't you watering it down
aren't you sort of you know taking it
out of the realm of philosophy which is
supposed to be abstract and you know
this high level of rationality and
putting it down there really throwing
your pearls amongst wine and my answer
to that that I'll talk about a little
bit more later is this is something that
philosophy has been doing for a very
very long time as a matter of fact it's
at the very core of philosophy as its
traditionally conceived of and practice
it's what makes philosophy exciting in
many respects there there is a lot of
stuff where you know we could be kind of
elitist about it or insist that like
Plato
those who have not studied geometry or
mathematics or set theory or pick
whatever you want may not enter here
before they walk into the Academy what
there's a lot of things where philosophy
does impact the the broader world that
we live in the life world as as people
have called it what I want to talk about
are four things right off the bat demand
need capacity and opportunity and what
do I mean by these well there is a
demand out there for doing philosophy in
a more accessible way in a way that
ordinary people who are not necessarily
going to college or who are not studying
philosophy in an academic manner can
make use of these range from lifelong
learners who want to know something
about the history of ideas to
professionals who have to deal with
critical thinking or ethics on a daily
basis to students and other fields who
may not even have an inkling that this
stuff would turn them on so there's this
incredible hunger out there that I
didn't realize that first exists for
substantive engagement with ideas that's
what demand is and so there is a real
demand to be given philosophy as well as
you know real history real literature
real religious studies and not to have
it you know just spoon fed or
oversimplified but to have it provided
to people in an accessible way so that's
that's an important element and I think
there's also a need and when I talk
about need and contrast it to demand
what I mean there is with demand people
know that they want something with need
quite often people don't realize that
philosophy at least is practiced by by
some philosophers is exactly what the
doctor ordered so you know business
people
they struggle to to conceptualize how
they want to approach their workplaces
and how to raise the standards for
ethics and they try a lot of experiments
you know to their credit I think most
business people actually are quite
interested in having an ethical
marketplace and having an ethical
workplace and having ethical practices
in place but it takes some it takes some
thinking and it really helps to have
some background in the discipline same
thing with critical thinking you know
that's a buzzword among educators but if
you actually go to educators you can say
what exactly is critical thinking most
of them on the spot can't give you any
sort of satisfactory I don't say
definition but even characterization or
enumeration some of them will even point
you to Bloom's hierarchy which is not
critical thinking that's that's a whole
different thing because there's been a
meme circulating around so this is one
of those those those areas where
philosophers can really come in and
contribute you know ethics critical
thinking a good grasp of the history of
ideas you know a lot of the big ideas
that have formed the world that we live
in came to us through philosophers and
were actually worked out and and
popularized through philosophers some of
them we now associate with with other
disciplines but many of those
disciplines are actually spin-offs from
philosophy so sometimes it's really
helpful to have a philosopher who not
only understands you know something from
a textbook or from a particular field
but it has a broader understanding of
you know how these ideas came to be and
why they were held to be valuable or
valid or worth you know disseminating I
think that it's also good you never know
what happens when you bring a
philosopher in a well trained
philosopher because there's certainly
habits of thinking that that you know
the discipline really promotes habits of
paying close attention to structures and
unraveling them and seeing how things
work and that we have a lot in common
with engineers or systems designers you
know
thinking about texts and how to how to
read them how to make sense of them
thinking being able to recognize common
human situations all these sorts of
issues they're very hard to wrap your
head around but they're the sort of
things that we do in philosophy when
we're doing philosophy in a in a
meaningful way not in a purely academic
abstract professionalized way so that's
that's need then there's capacity when I
talk about capacity what I mean is that
there are a lot of people out there in
in philosophy departments and also in
many other departments as well in
history departments poli-sci departments
English departments people who are doing
philosophy in other ways some artists
some musicians some business you know or
economics people some policymakers
there's a lot of there's a lot of people
out there who whether they realize it or
not they have what it takes to do
philosophy in a in a public or a popular
or a practical way engaged with with
other people dealing with the kinds of
problems that that we face so many of
them may not even suspect this to be the
case the last thing I want to talk about
and I'm gonna talk a lot more about this
later on is opportunity I think that
right now in large part because of the
internet and in part because of the
technology that we have available to us
like you know cheap flip cams that we
can record things with and editing
software we're in a unique position as
far as the ability to turn that capacity
of you know philosophers who are you
know in the past would be confined to
their little college their little
library their little you know circle and
it would be just be totally random if
they managed to like you know make their
way into the public sphere or they were
well-connected and you know they just
we're doing a philosophy as a sideline
they at that time that still goes on
quite if
there's still an elite system and
hierarchies and all that but the
internet opens up the opportunity for
you know for example somebody like me
who doesn't have an Ivy League or a big
state background who didn't attend the
right schools who just happened to
really love reading books and could talk
with people about philosophy to be able
to shoot videos and have people around
the world say yeah I like this stuff
I want some more of it why don't you
come and give a talk here so opportunity
really exists for for doing that and it
doesn't even have to be on the side of
the producers it's also on the side of
those who would like to to learn about
philosophy now you know if you it's not
as if you can in fact get a complete
public or you know education just by
watching youtube videos although you can
all you can learn an awful lot can't you
we have texts available online you can
access notes and commentaries by people
there are some free courses out there
you can connect by email or by social
media with the people who are actually
doing interesting work in philosophy we
have meetups that publicize hey there's
going to be a talk here or there's going
to be a philosophy cafe over here
something by the way we're trying to get
started in the Hudson Valley that's a
whole different story so demand need
capacity opportunity
these are answers to why do philosophy
in a public or practical or popular way
I mentioned earlier that somebody might
ask why are you philosophers coming out
of your classrooms coming out of your
offices coming out of your departmental
buildings and intruding yourself into
you know the World Wide Web the
marketplace or other people's offices
libraries pick whatever else you like
walking into restaurants and certain
conversations with people and the answer
to that is actually pretty simple
that's what philosophy
always did it's not as if philosophy as
a discipline had its beginnings in some
sort of totally isolated esoteric
enterprise that could only be engaged in
by a few as a matter of fact think about
Socrates and Plato and Aristotle and
people like like that well you know as
well as the other people before them who
were doing philosophy granted Heraclitus
thought most people are dummies and you
really can't do anything for them so
he's wrote in an obscure way but
Socrates would talk with anybody he was
interested in finding out who knew
something and whether there was any
wisdom and putting things to the test
and saying to people hey take care of
your soul that's more important than
just your body or your reputation or
your private property and and you know
he he did this gem
generously and he did this in an open
public way that's part of what God I'm
killed of course you know but hopefully
that's not going to be too much of an
issue although sometimes you know it is
an issue until talat aryan societies or
in other cases i don't want to dwell on
that too much but you know it's it's
been something of the very essence of
philosophy to make arguments to to
analyze claims to you know put projects
before the public eye over and over and
over again
I mean Plato wrote books Plato didn't
just say I'm only gonna you know teach a
select few he wrote books that we can
access today that have come down
throughout the ages Aristotle you know
he did have his Lyceum he benefited
greatly by having a patron like
Alexander the Great who could send him
specimens from all over the place where
his troops had gone to there's a whole
interesting story there but Aristotle
wrote even the guys who didn't
necessarily write things down like
epictetus had somebody to say man I need
to write this stuff down because this is
great and somebody needs to to
actually preserve this and thank God
that that his disciple Aryan did that
because you know look at the the
wonderful stuff that we have in
epictetus is discourses so you know you
could go down the line you know
Descartes thought that he was going to
revolutionize intellectual life and
society you know he had big plans Hegel
philosophy is definitely something that
brings all the other things together
reflects on them and does so in a public
way and and so you know we can go down
all the way to the present there's
always gonna be some charlatans there's
always going to be some snake oil
salesmen calling what they do philosophy
Plato talks about that already in the
Republic right but there's always going
to be some other people out there who
are who are doing philosophy in a public
way in a practical way in a popular way
that ordinary people can relate to and
benefit from and some of those will get
preserved in you know for future
generations and we can study them we can
make them part of our lives and rich
ourselves and our relationships and our
environments and our our institutions
with them that's that's a something
available to us because people have been
doing philosophy that way so it's really
sort of an aberration an anomaly to have
this hyper scholastic way of doing
academic philosophy where you know
somebody has to have all sorts of
prerequisites to even walk in the door
you know granted I'm not saying that you
know if you want to read Hegel you can
just jump right in and make perfect
sense of it you know and start to you
know criticize him on the basis of this
or that without understanding it but
it's it's open it's available it
sometimes takes you know the work of
commentators to help out with this but
but that's something again going back to
this issue of opportunity we're in a
unique situation now because of the the
you know the resources of the internet
so you know philosophy in the way that
we're talking
gameband it is something public
something popular something practical
it's really not that new in a way it's
to go back to the very roots of
philosophy there are some things that
you know you have to do some cultivation
to fully understand but I tend to think
that most people are capable of that
some people have wondered how I got you
know the idea to start doing philosophy
the way that I'm doing it and you know
the story really isn't that dramatic
it's it's more a matter of sort of
chance or fortuitous or perhaps
Providence and it has a lot less to do
with my own planning most of my own
plans have tended to go awry and turn
into something completely different and
it was much more about people coming
along and saying you know why don't you
try this and encouraging me and you know
the technology and the tools being being
available to me and then finding out
that it was the kind of thing that I
could get into the kind of thing that I
liked I would say that the very
beginnings of doing philosophy in a more
public popular way for me have to do
with service I think that because I was
I was good at understanding difficult to
understand philosophers or texts there
would be people who'd come along and
this happened all the way back in under
my undergrad days I'm gonna happen more
in graduate school when I would lead
reading groups or you know have just
some private tutoring or things like
that people would come along and say
look you seem to understand this Hegel
guy can you you know help us out in
understanding the phenomenology of
spirit and you know I think it's also
helpful to have the boldness of youth
that sort of thing because looking back
at some of the things that I jumped into
back then even like my book project
that that culminated and reason
fulfilled by revelation you know if I
were to think about it rationally now
and say should I do that
I think the you know the older me might
say yeah that you need to pass on that
one but you know you you jump into
things and then over time you start to
develop skills and it's one of those
things that you you learn as you go and
you get better as you I was just
listening to a podcast of a my very
first paid academic lecture and I don't
mean they no teaching I mean where I was
invited to go to a school and give a
lecture it was a 2008 st. Anselm lecture
and I was listening to how I spoke with
the crowd at that time and I was
thinking wow I've gotten a lot better
when it comes to this sort of thing in
managing to reach people and managing to
field questions and in doing the sort of
things that are required for academic
philosophy and I thought well how did
that happen it's learning by doing it's
it's repetition you throw yourself out
there and you never know how an audience
is going to actually react to what it is
that you're bringing before them but the
good thing is if you're doing philosophy
well you have a high quality product
that in many cases will sort of sell
itself you know if you're gonna talk
about Plato or Nietzsche or you know the
card you know these great heavy hitters
in philosophy and you actually know
something about it and you can
communicate it to somebody else there's
a reason why people keep going back to
these books because of the great ideas
in them and all you have to do is be
kind of like a a mediator all you have
to do is be an interpreter and you know
somebody to put it in front of them and
say what do you think about this so I
didn't awful lot of that sort of stuff
and there you know I've been doing
public talks in various places libraries
churches
other colleges and universities most
recently I started doing radio spots for
as a philosopher and in each case you're
doing something a bit different it's a
different audience and you know when
people ask you to do this kind of stuff
I think you know if you if you've got
the the ability to do it and you know
your philosophy you jump into it because
you're helping out the field you're
spreading this this this great you know
available wisdom that people have
bequeathed to us that were part of a
conversation you you awaken that demand
you may actually satisfy people's needs
I also think that philosophers as
philosophers need to be a lot more
involved in things outside of philosophy
where philosophy can satisfy a kind of
need you know so philosophers should be
in hospitals helping people off with
with with medical ethics questions if
they're properly trained in medical
ethics philosophers should be out there
coming in and giving guest lectures in
high schools helping high school and
middle school teachers to actually
infuse real critical thinking or ethics
into their curriculum helping them to
understand that sort of thing
philosophers ought to be sitting on
boards philosophers ought to be engaging
in you know local and and dare I even
say state and national politics by the
way I'm not the guy for that sort of
thing I can't stand that's for that sort
of business but but they should be doing
that sort of thing and there are some
who do that I just think that there
aren't quite quite enough so you know my
own example I got drawn into something
that I never realized that would have
been any good at assessment of student
learning because there was a need at my
university Fayetteville State University
for assessing things having to do with
thinking and I was teaching a lot of
critical thinking classes and I I you
know encountered some interesting
assessment tools I started thinking
about this as a philosopher and then I
started realizing man I can do some of
this stuff in ways that the education
people who you know grant a masters in
education and have you know masters and
PhDs in education they can't even do or
even sometimes see their way to or
conceptualize I found that I could help
the business people I developed it you
know or co-developed a business ethics
and business education program at FSU as
well because there was a genuine need
there for it and the business people
were like hey come on in and help us out
you know the our accrediting agency
wants us to be doing some stuff with
ethics we're really antsy with this our
textbooks aren't very good can you can
you help us out so that's how I got
drawn into this and then you know of
course the YouTube channel there's a
whole story there a lot of it has to do
with people pushing me to record my
videos and then then people on the other
end responding positively and saying hey
I like this stuff it's helping me out
can you do some more and I just kept on
with that and and eventually it became
something I could see doing if not
completely full-time at least you know
about half of my time ends up being
devoted to video production and planning
and editing and all that sort of stuff
and it's really helped out my my own
teaching it's helped out my own research
there there's a lot of things as a
philosopher that when you get yourself
out of your comfort zone you're gonna
make more sense out of you know you
might not think to yourself that
shooting YouTube videos has anything to
do with you know Plato and understanding
Plato's dialogues I find that it does
and there's a whole long conversation
that we can have there I suppose
in any case there's all different ways
in which you can get involved in in
doing philosophy in public or popular
and I encourage anybody who's interested
in that to do so let's talk as I finish
this up about some of the opportunities
that the internet really throws in our
lap to do philosophy in a in a public in
a practical a popular way so I I'm going
to actually gear my my discussion here
not so much at people who might want to
do something similar to what I'm doing
but to a much broader audience if you
like philosophy we live in a time now
where there's lots of clubs and
organizations and events and the
Internet is an amazing environment for
finding all of this sort of stuff first
of all you can find local events near
you you know go to you know look in
Facebook and type in things use Google
search to look for anything in your
surrounding area if you're in a
university setting a university town you
probably have a whole bunch of different
interesting events by you but check out
local libraries check out bookstores
check out you know philosophy cafes
there's also a whole penumbra of other
kinds of events and organizations where
it might not be explicitly about
philosophy but where it really is going
to touch on philosophy great example of
this the death cafe movement we have a
death cafe here in Kingston and although
it goes in other areas I haven't gone to
it yet but I but I keep meaning to it
usually ends up being at the same time
as another event that I have to go to
and what do the people do there what's
it says movement where where people get
together and they have some coffee and
and some you know donuts or bagels or
whatever and they talk and an
unstructured way about death one of
these fundamental existential realities
that we have to face up to a
philosophical theme that people have
been discussing since Socrates was
sentenced to die and you know said to
people well this isn't so bad
even though you think it is
there's all sorts of things along these
lines and you just have to you just have
to do a little bit of legwork to find it
and we're so fortunate today that we've
got the Internet and you don't have to
like you know walk around to all the
different places and look for you know
little notices or posters or things like
that there's probably a lot of websites
that you can get out and put your name
in and and you know it'll alert you to
that sort of thing so that's local and
then you know outside of your local area
you you can participate in all sorts of
cool philosophy related and you know
even touching on philosophy kind of
matters because other people out there
doing the work to organize them great
example of this starting next week it's
stoical week and these guys at the
university I think it's Exeter started a
blog and then they created a handbook
because they were interested in stoicism
and and now they've got a class an
online class if by the way I enrolled in
this year and you know one week out of
the year we focus intensively on
stoicism and you can do it in connection
with people on the other side of the
planet from you you can trade ideas back
and forth you can talk about yeah I this
is what I got out of Epictetus what did
you get out of Epictetus so there's all
sorts of really great things like that
YouTube is a wonderful resource I don't
know how many philosophy videos are out
there and they're all different kinds I
mean I tend to shoot these very low low
tech di you know do-it-yourself it's all
about the content man kind of kind of
things that people like and and you know
some of my videos are an hour and a half
long and people will watch them all the
way through other people do very short
punchy you know high production kinds of
you know thumbnail sketch videos and
some people really like that
the great thing about about the Internet
is you get this entire smorgasbord set
out in front of you so whatever it is
that helps you with it use that if it's
going to help you learn about Plato or
it's gonna help you learn about
Aristotle or Augustine I'm for it now
there's there's some other stuff that I
would like to say to people who might
think about getting into this this line
of line of work and I think that looking
back on it there's really four things
that are necessary if you wanted to do
something like say build a YouTube
channel or start doing public speaking
about about philosophy in local areas
and so two of them have to do with sort
of you know competence issues and then
the other two are other factors so the
two competence based issues one of them
is you actually have to know something
about philosophy you can't just walk in
and say well I really like Plato but I
don't know anything about him I'm gonna
start a conversation about it and see
where it goes because they have some or
just a [ __ ] section and if there's
room for that sort of thing having
watched Monty Python skits about
philosophy not quite enough to go on
because that's out of such a superficial
level if you want to get something that
will resonate with other people you know
you've got to be able to answer
questions for them you've got to be able
to go in and and reveal to something
reveal to them something that they
didn't already know about Aristotle so
you do have to know your area does that
mean that you have to be a complete
expert no do you have to publish you
know all sorts of books on the subject
of course not you know a great example
the half hour Hegel series there are
better Hegel commentators out there who
have many books and articles to their
credit than I am but I'm the guy who
actually decided to shoot the videos and
who's putting in the work to do it I do
know my Hegel
you know I been studying him for well
it's like 20 years now yeah about 20
years of actual study okay go
but you know I've only published one
article on on Hegel in my entire career
I've published on on other people
instead you don't have to be the top of
the field expert to be able to have a
good productive conversation with people
where you teach them something
now maybe after they've exhausted what
you have to give them then they need to
go on to somebody else but that will
usually take a while so you need
competence in the sense of being a you
know an intermediate or expert level in
what you're going to talk about you also
need something that's a little bit
harder to to quantify and that is an
ability to connect with with ordinary
people people who are not professional
philosophers who may not in fact realize
that this stuff is intrinsically
valuable or interesting until you bring
it across to them I don't know how you
develop those those sorts of skills I
know for me it really helped to have to
teach class after class after class of
undergraduates who were not particularly
interested in taking a philosophy class
because I had to like stretched to be
able to do that I think some people are
more natural at that other people are
you know a little bit less liable to
engage in that it probably helps to be
open to other people to get away from
the sense that you know I'm the sage on
the stage I'm just gonna teach all of
you shut up and listen you got to
actually like other people I think
there's people to come across well to
other people but you know the many of
the great philosophers were people who
liked people Rene Descartes he didn't
like you know obstinate bigoted people
but he liked people in general
Socrates even
talk with anybody you know we could we
can go on and on like that then another
thing you really need to have is some
sort of passion or excitement interest
that you can communicate to your your
audience so you know you you really
should if you're gonna try to get into
doing lectures or shooting videos do it
about stuff that you love first now I
I'm you know a professional teacher so I
can be a bit more disinterested in in a
text at a topic I can appreciate it in a
kind of you know way that's that's not
quite so about it being excited and more
about well this is a great work of
philosophy like you know Immanuel Kant
Immanuel Kant does not you know trip my
triggers what I recognize is a great
philosopher and I enjoy you know talking
about can't you you notice I don't have
any publications on cuz I you know I
don't want to write about Conte I've got
other stuff that I'm more excited about
that I would rather write like Aristotle
you know but if you ask me to do a
lecture I'm cut yeah
why not great philosopher interesting
ideas I think he's wrong on a lot of
stuff but you know first before we worry
about whether he's right or wrong we got
to figure out what the guy actually said
so you need you need to have some sort
of passion or excitement or interest in
what you're teaching and then the fourth
thing it is perseverance if you're going
to start a YouTube channel or you're
gonna start giving talks it takes a
while before you get traction let me
tell you and it often I mean you'll
spend a lot of time that's been the case
for me showing up to places and having
three people in the audience that can
happen by the way in academic
conferences - I remember one time being
on a Hobbes panel where there were five
people on the panel and there were three
people in the audience you just got to
keep sticking with it you know and if
you keep on generating good content good
content in the sense that I talked about
before you know you're passionate about
what you're doing you actually know what
you're talking about you're able to come
with ordinary people eventually other
people are going to start to catch on to
it if you're if you're generating a
valuable product people will eventually
start liking your product and talking
about it with other people and with
philosophy you know you've got the at
least with the kind that I do I'm a
historian a philosophy I don't have to
reinvent any sort of wheels or come up
with anything new myself it's enough for
me to teach about these brilliant people
and they're great insights that they had
you know going back millennia I could be
doing videos the rest of my life just
about the people that I'm excited about
talking about it's it's an incredible
opportunity so you can do that too if
you want to or you don't have to you
just you know enjoy what other people
are producing there is a a genuine joy
in learning and in encountering truth in
using our minds this is the highest part
of us as human beings and there's
something really enjoyable about doing
that and that's what philosophy brings
so to bring this to a close once again
happy world philosophy day 2014 I hope
that you'll join me for the event that
I've got planned for it later on today
and you know sign up for stoic week and
look look for other philosophy related
things and I will see you next world
philosophy day 2015 and we'll have a
whole different conversation that